Das Grundproblem der Raumfahrt in einem Satz
zusammengefasst: Sie ist teuer, denn man benötigt
große Energien, um die Nutzlast auf extrem
hohe Geschwindigkeiten zu beschleunigen.
Ein Professor aus den USA schlägt jetzt eine
Lösung vor: Schwarze Löcher könnten als
eine Art Lichtschleuder dienen.
So könnten Raumschiffe extreme Geschwindigkeiten
erreichen und somit schnell und ohne großen
Treibstoffverbrauch im All umher reisen.
Also Raumschiffantrieb “Halo Drive”jetzt
in Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es
täglich faszinierende Sciencevideos abonniert
den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts, Los
geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Das ist eine ziemlich spannende Zukunftsvision
von David Kipping.
Er ist Astronom an der Columbia-University
und beschäftigt sich schon seit längerer
Zeit mit Schwarzen Löchern in Zusammenhang
mit der Raumfahrt.
Jetzt hat er eine Studie veröffentlicht,
in der er beschreibt, wie wir uns Schwarze
Löcher zunutze machen könnten, um bei einer
Reise durch das Weltall Energie und Zeit zu
sparen.
Kipping hält es für durchaus möglich, dass
wir schon bald bemannte Reisen über weite
Distanzen im All zurücklegen können - doch
dafür seien neue Technologien notwendig.
Schwarze Löcher könnten uns dabei helfen
- quasi als eine Art Beschleunigungssystem
im Weltraum.
Fangen wir von vorne an und zwar bei den sogenannten
Swing-by-Manövern, auf denen Kippings Idee
letztendlich basiert.
Schon seit den Voyager-Raumsonden wird diese
Technik genutzt, damit Raumsonden quasi kostenlos
Energie tanken können.
Die Gravitationskraft der Planeten wird hier
genutzt, um Raumsonden zu beschleunigen oder
auch abzubremsen.
Denn wenn die Sonde als leichter Körper nah
an einem vergleichsweise schweren Himmelskörper
vorbeifliegt, nimmt sie quasi Energie von
ihm.
So kann nicht nur die Geschwindigkeit, sondern
auch die Flugrichtung geändert werden.
Wenn die Raumsonde sich wieder entfernt, bremst
der Planet sie ab.
Das ist alles eine Frage der Perspektive:
Aus Sicht des Planeten verlässt die Raumsonde
ihn mit derselben Geschwindigkeit, wie sie
sich ihm angenähert hat - eben nur in eine
andere Richtung.
Aus Sicht der Sonne sieht das alles anders
aus.
So gesehen kommt zu der Geschwindigkeit der
Raumsonde die Geschwindigkeit des Planeten
hinzu.
Relativ zur Sonne gesehen ist sie also effektiv
schneller geworden.
Der Planet selbst wird durch die ganze Sache
einen minimalen Ticken langsamer, doch durch
seine gigantische Masse im Vergleich zur Raumsonde,
ist dies zu vernachlässigen.
Niemand kann seinen Geschwindigkeitsverlust
überhaupt messen.
Doch die Fähigkeiten dieser Swing-by-Schleuder
sind begrenzt.
Denn mit der Technik dieses Manövers lässt
sich die Geschwindigkeit maximal um die doppelte
Geschwindigkeit des Planeten erhöhen.
Der Merkur beispielsweise bewegt sich auf
seiner Bahn im Sonnensystem mit einer Geschwindigkeit
von 47,4 Kilometern pro Sekunde.
Für eine interstellare Reise aber braucht
man aber deutlich mehr - nämlich zumindest
relevante Bruchteile der Lichtgeschwindigkeit,
die ja bei knapp 300.000 Kilometer pro Sekunde
liegt.
In der Theorie gibt es Ideen, um dieses Manöver
effektiver zu gestalten und zwar mit Hilfe
eines engen Doppel-Neutronensterns.
Der US-Physiker Freeman Dyson hatte 1963 bereits
zwei Neutronensterne vorgeschlagen, die jeweils
etwa eine Sonnenmasse aufweisen und sich alle
fünf Millisekunden einmal umkreisen.
Ein Raumschiff könnte durch einen engen Vorbeiflug
auf bis zu 81.000 Kilometer pro Sekunde beschleunigt
werden - das entspricht 27 Prozent der Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Doch diese Überlegung enthält einen fatalen
Nachteil.
Die Gezeitenkräfte des Doppelneutronensterns
sind gigantisch und würden das Raumschiff
“spagetthifizieren”.
Dieser Begriff wurde von Stephen Hawking geprägt
und meint die Verformung von Objekten, wenn
diese in die Nähe eines Schwarzen Lochs geraten.
Es wird in zunächst in die Länge gezogen
und dann auseinandergerissen - bildlich gesehen
eben wie die Form von Spaghetti.
Doch klar ist auch: Nicht nur Schwarze Löcher
sind in der Lage, Objekte zu spaghettifizieren,
sondern eben auch Doppelneutronensterne.
Und damit kommen wir zurück zu dem Astronom
David Kipping und seiner aktuellen Arbeit.
Denn er hat sich eine Möglichkeit überlegt,
wie eine bemannte Reise im Weltall mit Hilfe
von Schwarzen Löchern noch schneller werden
könnte - und das eben OHNE das Risiko einzugehen,
am Ende als Spaghetti zu enden :) Konkret
schlägt Kipping vor, Schwarze Löcher als
Spiegel zu nutzen.
Dass die Objekte wie eine Art Spiegel wirken,
weiß man schon seit 1993.
Laut Kipping müsse Laserlicht sehr gezielt
an dem Schwarzen Loch, das einem entgegen
kommt, vorbei gelenkt werden.
Um das Schwarze Loch herum befindet sich das
sogenannte “Photonen-Halo”.
Das ist eine Zone, in der das Licht das Schwarze
Loch ein oder mehrmals umkreist.
Das Licht, das dem Schwarzen Loch ziemlich
nahe kommt, bleibt zunächst in diesem Photonen-Halo.
Außerhalb dieses bestimmten Radius aber rast
das Licht vorbei; wird in die Gegenrichtung
umgelenkt und kommt so wie in Bumerang zurück.
Mit einem Lichtsegel könnt das Raumschiff
die Photonen dann wieder auffangen.
Vereinfacht gesagt wird also der Effekt, dass
Schwarze Löcher wie ein Spiegel wirken und
Photonen wieder zu ihrer Ursprungsquelle zurück
schleudern, ausgenutzt.
Kipping nennt diese ultimative Schleuder “Halo-Drive”.
Raumschiffe schießen also Laserstrahlen in
Richtung des Schwarzen Lochs und die Photonen,
die zurückkehren, werden mit einem Segel
wieder eingefangen.
So kann an Geschwindigkeit zugelegt werden,
ohne dass viel Energie benötigt wird.
Das Ganze berechnet Kipping auch mit Hilfe
von komplizierten Formeln.
Letztendlich kommt er zu dem Ergebnis, dass
so eine Endgeschwindigkeit erreichen werden
könnte, die bei 133 Prozent der Geschwindigkeit
des Schwarzen Lochs liegt.
In Kippings Vision könnte die Raumfahrt in
Zukunft die rund 10 Millionen Schwarzen Löcher,
die es Schätzungen zufolge in der Milchstraße
gibt, als eine Art Express-Autobahnsystem
nutzen.
Quer durch die Galaxie reisen auf riesigen
Netzwerken von interstellaren Autobahnen!
Und sich so von einer Station zur nächsten
schießen lassen.
Wow, was für ein irrer, aber gleichzeitig
auch genialer Gedanke!
Kipping schreibt auch, dass ein Raumschiff
nicht unbedingt selbst seine eigene Laserlichtquelle
mitbringen muss.
Ein entsprechender Laser könnte stattdessen
auch auf einem Planeten installiert werden.
Zudem könnten statt Licht auch Teilchenstrahlen,
also eine Art Ionenantrieb, genutzt werden.
Schaut man sich die Relativitätstheorie genauer
an, wird klar, dass es theoretisch gesehen
tatsächlich möglich ist, Bruchteile der
Lichtgeschwindigkeit zu erreichen.
Der von Kipping beschriebene Halo-Drive sorgt
dafür, dass mehr Photonenenergie zurückbleibt
als anfangs aufgewendet wurde.
In der Theorie könnten somit also ganze Planetenmassen
in Bewegung versetzt werden.
Offen lässt Kipping dennoch eine wichtige
Frage: Wie können wir ein geeignetes Schwarzes
Loch in angemessener Zeit erreichen?
Kipping hat angekündigt, sich mit diesem
Aspekt in seinen noch folgenden Arbeiten zu
beschäftigen.
Denn wenn dieses Problem nicht gelöst wird,
bleibt die Idee reine Theorie.
Schwarze Löcher erklärt Draufklicken, Anschauen
und Bytethinks abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!